the roller coaster on wall street
creating some uncertainty among certain
investors joe mohler spoke to a local
economic expert about what this could
mean for all of us
stocks opened tuesday in a bear market
following a big drop monday that means
it's down 20 percent from its peak i
think it's creating a lot of concern for
the public and the investing public
brian gordon is a principal from applied
analysis it causes folks to reevaluate
their personal financial situation and
hopefully somebody that's on the brink
of retirement has really you know
migrated into some securities and things
that are a little bit more
stable as opposed to the roller coaster
ride we're seeing in the stock market
today multiple factors are playing a
role in the market we have some global
conflict happening we're seeing
gas prices through the roof inflation in
general is off the charts at 40-year
highs and then there's a lot of talk
about the federal reserve trying to tamp
down what's happening in terms of the
economic growth the central bank is set
to meet wednesday to consider another
interest rate hike that could be three
quarters of a point it's going to be
tricky the the feds are looking to sort
of thread this needle if you will in
terms of balancing inflation interest
rates the economy like in years past
this dramatic drop could bounce back
gordon says this market is creating
worry for those nearing retirement with
savings tied to a 401k account i think
you've got to take a little bit of a
wait-and-see attitude in terms of what
what's going to ultimately unfold here
joe muller live local now
[Music]